(calm music)
(pen scratches)
- My name is Charlie
and I'm nine years old.
- And my name is Jake
and I'm seven years old.
- I really want a perm
because all the girls
would think I'm handsome.
I'd also want a lot of money.
- I really want Robux, lots of them,
because I could buy cool
stuff on my Roblox account.
- If I get my perm, I
promise to comb it every day,
to make sure it looks nice.
If I get money, I will buy hair products
to make sure my perm looks
its very best every day.
That's all for now.
(air swooshes)
(many people laugh)
(audience applauds)
- It's literally my favorite thing, ever
that this kid asked for a perm.
How ridiculously cute is that?
- That is my favorite
thing I've ever seen.
(Jewel laughs)
(many people laugh)
- That was very cute.
- I love that so much.
- It's, like, you just don't
see it coming and it does.
Well, welcome back everybody.
Jewel and Andrea Savage are with us,
hanging out.
(audience applauds)
And, all week we have teamed up
with our season-long
partner, Pilot FriXion Pen,
the go-to, erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
We are taking a little
pressure off old Saint Nick
and helping answer some
hand-written letters to Santa.
Charlie and Jake, we want
to celebrate kids like you,
creating fearless and
bold holiday letters,
and just being awesome.
I love you.
So, we're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
(audience applauds)
Charlie,
you go and get that perm
(laughs) and all the
hair products you desire,
and Jake, you'll be all set with Roblox.
My kids love that too.
Merry Christmas, y'all.